one summer I realized you know what I
think Khan Academy actually has all of
this for me so I spent the summer
looking at it and I had two algebra
classes and I I used one for like
completely Khan Academy I want you guys
to watch the videos do all the quizzes
homework tests and we're gonna see how
it is and the other class I taught from
the front and did my traditional lesson
plans like that and it was pretty
evident by Christmas that the kids that
were able to you know that I was able to
move around and not teach from the front
those kids were advancing more once I
get going it's like I'm helping this kid
and I'm helping this kid and you know
kids are waiting and so then all of a
sudden they're starting to help each
other and it's just like this this
Socratic method that is just uh it's
it's amazing to watch and I get
goosebumps every time I think about it
and I realize that as a tiny school and
being the only math teacher it gives me
that flexibility but I think you know
with just a little bit of creativity I
think bigger schools could do the same
thing because it's still all in their
Khan Academy account it's documented
that they've learned it that they've
mastered it kids that just spent 20
minutes a day
averaged an 80 percent or above
80 percent of it was unbelievable